zdf heute live herzlich willkommen in
heidelberg hat am mittag ein bewaffneter
angreifer mehrere menschen verwundet und
sich danach selbst getötet also offenbar
einen amoklauf laut polizei hatte sich
dabei um einen einzeltäter gehandelt der
in einem hörsaal der universität mit
einer langwaffe also einem gewehr das
feuer eröffnet und dann mehrere personen
teilweise schwer verletzt hat die
polizei ist im großeinsatz oder war ist
zumindest das gebiet um den hörsaal
herum wurde abgesperrt
und wir sprechen mit unserem kollegen
vor ort mit anton ja nie ein paar sachen
habe ich jetzt gerade schon skizziert
anton was weiß man sonst noch bislang
über das tatgeschehen und wie ist die
aktuelle lage vor ort
ich stehe hier auf dem gelände der
universitätsklinik in heidelberg über
uns kreist noch der hubschrauber aber
die gefahrenlage die ist offiziell
beendet so hat es die polizei hier in
heidelberg verkündet ja der fall scheint
klar im moment muss natürlich noch
aufgearbeitet werden irgendwann heute
nachmittag kurz vor halb eins hat dieser
unbekannte mann bisher unbekannte mann
einen hörsaal betreten und hat sofort
angefangen um sich zu schießen heißt es
nähere informationen kann mir der
pressesprecher der polizei aus mannheim
stephan wilhelm geben herr wilhelm weiß
man denn schon was über die hintergründe
dieses mannes über die hintergründe über
das motiv des täters das ist aktuell
völlig unklar um kurz vor halb eins ist
diese männliche person in einen hörsaal
hier im neuenheimer feld eingedrungen
hat vermutlich mittels einer langwaffe
um sich geschossen und dabei mehrere
personen verletzt im anschluss ist der
täter dann geflüchtet und hat sich auf
seiner flucht selbst hingerichtet die
gerüchte koch gerüchteküche kocht
natürlich in solchen fällen immer
gewaltig es war die rede von mehreren
waffen es war zwischendurch auch mal die
rede von mehreren tätern das kann
inzwischen ausgeschlossen werden von
seiten der polizei also mehrere täter
das kann ausgeschlossen werden wir gehen
von einem einzeltäter aus das sek hat
hier das gesamte gelände durchsucht rein
aus vorsicht um einen zweiten täter
auszuschließen das können wir definitiv
aktuell ausschließen wir gehen von einem
einzeltäter aus sie gehen von einer
großen gefahrenlage aus wie lange was
hat denn wie hat denn der notrufe aus
gesehen der bei der polizei eingegangen
ist ja um kurz vor halb eins hat uns ein
notruf erreicht und dann wurde die
rettungskette in gang gesetzt der
anrufer oder die anruferin dazu können
wir aktuell auch noch keine hin keine
angaben machen das wird sich im lauf der
ermittlungen jetzt alles herausstellen
wie die rettungskette in gang gesetzt
wurde weiß man denn schon etwas was sich
genau abgespielt hat ist der mann hinein
in den hörsaal hat sofort gezielt oder
wild um sich geschossen über den genauen
ablauf der tat können wir aktuell keine
angaben machen ja man ist dann
geflüchtet aus dem hörsaal ins gelände
der der universitätsklinik hat es lange
gedauert ihn zu finden oder hat man
diesen täter dann nur tot gefunden die
rettungskette die ist sehr schnell in
gang gesetzt worden unsere kollegen die
waren sehr zügig vor ort den täter
konnten sie dann im laufe der flucht
leider nur noch tot auffinden jetzt wird
aufgearbeitet nähere informationen wird
es heute abend gehen und 19 uhr bei
einer pressekonferenz in mannheim das
ist das was man im moment aktuell aus
heidelberg erzählen kann ja vielen dank
anton ja nie bis hierhin wir könnten
jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen
weitermachen und gucken ob wir ich meine
du hast gerade mit dem polizisten
gesprochen also das ist der aktuelle
kenntnisstand aber trotzdem ist es
vielleicht noch mal ganz interessant
wenn wir uns vielleicht auch noch mal
untereinander fragen wie es eigentlich
möglich war dass der täter an gleich
mehrere gewehre herangekommen ist gibt
das schon irgendwelche ja mutmaßungen
wie das geschehen sein kann denn die
sind ja noch nicht so leicht zu bekommen
es ist so dass die rede war von mehreren
gewähren diese informationen ist bisher
noch nicht bestätigt die polizei geht
davon aus dass es sich um eine langwaffe
gehandelt hat dieses wurde bestimmt
wurde bestätigt mehrere gewehre scheint
in dem bereich der gerüchteküche zu
laufen wie der täter der ja auch noch
nicht bekannt ist oder über den noch
nichts bekannt wurde an ein gewehr
gekommen ist darüber kann man im moment
noch nicht sagen da laufen die in
komplette die ermittlung und der polizei
natürlich auch laufen die ermittlungen
in richtung motiv das der täter hatte
warum um sich geschossen hat es hält
sich hartnäckig das gerücht dass es sich
um einen studenten gehandelt hat mehr
kann man im moment noch nicht nicht über
den täter sagen ja dann vielleicht noch
ganz kurz dass es also eine langwaffe
war das haben wir gehört das ergibt sich
aus dem waffengesetz was das ist das im
schusswaffen das kann ich gerade
vielleicht mal hier vortragen deren lauf
und verschluss in geschlossener stellung
insgesamt länger als 30 cm sind und
deren kürzeste bestimmungen
genau gesamtlänge mindestens 60
zentimeter dann aber doch überschreitet
also auf gut deutsch es ist ein gewehr
das haben wir jetzt ja auch gerade schon
gehört wie gesagt es gibt noch keine
belastbaren erkenntnisse darüber wie
viele davon im einsatz waren und wo der
täter diese hier gehabt haben könnte die
frage vielleicht gerade noch mal ob wir
nochmal lokalisieren können wo das ganze
sich zugetragen hat also du hattest es
vorhin schon gesagt das ganze an der
universität ich glaube wir haben das
auch grafisch vorbereitet vielleicht
kann man da gerade noch einen blick
drauf werfen wo das ganze war ja da ist
ein großes ja es ist ein großes gelände
hier das universitätsgelände ist ein
großes gelände da gibt es viele
institute da gibt es viele hörsäle und
in einen dieser hörsäle hat sich das
zugetragen wir stehen jetzt hier vor der
chirurgische klinik alte chirurgie heißt
es hier und bei der pathologie es ist
ein riesen medienaufgebot von überall
sind kamerateams fotografen hier
die details die gibt die polizei
natürlich noch nicht preis weil das
alles kleinigkeiten sind die wichtig
sind für die ermittlungen und da will
die polizei logischerweise am anfang
noch nicht so viel preisgeben um die
ermittlungen auch entsprechend in die
richtige richtung lenken zu können
nadine obst fragt uns über facebook wie
viele leute sind verletzt das können wir
vielleicht gerade noch mal wiederholen
das waren vier personen und davon eine
schwerer wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe
ja über die schwere der verletzungen
gibt die polizei auch noch keine
informationen heraus es geht teilweise
auch darum die menschen zu schützen ihre
familien zu schützen deshalb ist die
polizei da sehr zurückhaltend mit ihren
informationen dass sie nicht zu viele
informationen raus gibt dass die
menschen über die medien erfahren dass
eventuell ein gehöriger von ihnen
verletzt wurde vielleicht sogar schwer
verletzt wurde deshalb hält die polizei
solche informationen eigentlich auch
ganz gerne zurück um das ganze in ruhige
bahnen zu lenken um dann die leute die
angehörigen zu informieren
sie sagten vier personen die verletzt
sind eine davon schwer die informationen
kann ich an meiner stelle jetzt so nicht
bestätigen
kommt auch irgendwoher aus irgendeiner
leitung die polizei hat diese zahl mir
gegenüber habe jetzt gerade ja den
pressesprecher neben mir und habe vorher
auch längere zeit mit ihm reden können
die polizei hat diese informationen
bisher nicht bestätigt versteh ja gut
das sind die agenturmeldungen die das
schreiben aber hier nein ich muss es
sagen die polizei mannheim 4 personen
über twitter in ihrem neuesten statement
vier personen zum teil schwer verletzt
also auch da jetzt nicht spezifisch aber
da steht eben auch im gleichen tweet das
jetzt aktuell keine gefahr mehr besteht
aber das wäre jetzt auch meine nächste
frage gewesen wie es aktuell die
situation denn eigentlich vor ort also
ist da so was wie ich weiß es nicht also
ist da jetzt eine bedrückende stille zu
spüren gehen die die leute weiter zu uni
ist das alles abgesperrt ist überhaupt
gar kein betrieb mehr wie ist im moment
die lage vor ort
also das gelände ist großräumig
abgesperrt das uni gelände darf in das
uni gelände darf nur rein wer ein
dringendes bedürfnis hat hier rein zu
kommen sei es als lehrer als student
ansonsten darf man hier nicht reinfahren
es ist weiträumig abgesperrt man sieht
überall auch im umfeld dieses geländes
polizei die dasteht polizeiwagen die die
umgebung die die menschen die hier in
der gegend unterwegs sind beobachten
also die polizei ist da sehr aufmerksam
hier auf dem gelände ist natürlich eine
wenn man so will
rege
beschäftigung von kamerateams von
fotografen jeder möchte hier ein
interview haben von dem polizeisprecher
die sind hier von der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit mit mehreren
menschen vor ort und geben bereitwillig
auskünfte so weit wie es geht aber
sieht man dann dem einen oder anderen an
der hätte vielleicht auch gerne mehr
erfahren von dem polizeisprecher aber
das geht im moment so nicht auf der
anderen seite hast du jetzt auch noch
keine studenten gesehen oder
studentinnen die da sitzen weinend oder
irgendwie
nach fassung ringend oder vielleicht
irgendwie also das ist ich versuche
gerade einfach mal ein bisschen die die
atmosphäre vor ort irgendwie zu erfragen
weil ich mein wenn man dann dort ist
dann denkt man ja vielleicht auch es
hätte ein selbst treffen können
derlei beobachtung konntest du bislang
nicht machen
das erstaunt nicht die studenten und
studentinnen die ich gesehen habe die
einen hier an diesem medienaufgebot
vorbei die wollen eigentlich auch keine
auskünfte geben die laufen hier vorbei
wenn ich so nach hinten gucken da hinten
ist die chirurgische klinik dort haben
sich die betreuer dort haben sich
seelsorger postiert und die betreuenden
studenten die dabei waren sind jetzt
auch für die angehörigen da die jetzt
hierher gerufen zu den studenten und
studentinnen die von der von von dem
überfall von dem amoklauf betroffenen
waren auch die leute die nicht verletzt
sind die nicht körperlich verletzt sind
die sind vielleicht seelisch verletzt
und die werden dann von seelsorgern
betreut
und das findet ganz das ganze findet
hier hinter mir statt
jetzt erreicht uns gerade eine meldung
der dpa der deutschen presse agentur
dass es offenbar doch einen toten gibt
unter den opfern also das schwer
verletzte opfer offenbar gestorben das
wirst du jetzt auch noch nicht
bestätigen können aber das ist die
information die ich jetzt gerade bekomme
er urlaub schreibt uns über youtube dass
so jemand einfach nicht auffällt das ist
einfach nur versagen unseres
sicherheitsapparats ja nun wenn die
gewehre oder das gewehr versteckt waren
am körper dann ist es vielleicht auch
nicht so einfach dass das auffällt ich
weiß nicht ob man da jetzt schon vor dem
versagen unsere sicherheitsapparat
sprechen kann
ich weiß nicht ob du sonst noch weitere
jahr vielleicht dazu noch eine anmerkung
von dir
ja es ist einfach so
sicherheit infrage zu stellen ist eine
eine ist die eine sache aber die
menschen wollen wir auch nicht diesen
sogenannten sicherheitsapparat das
überall polizei steht das überall
kontrolliert wird das war verhältnisse
haben wir in amerika wo es nur noch mit
mit schleusen geht wo man in schulen
darf nur in schulen rein darf wenn man
vorher gescannt wurde ob man eine waffe
dabei hat das wäre so das wäre so die
richtung wo man von sicherheitsapparat
sprechen kann das möchte hier in
deutschland niemand und verhindern
können solche einrichtungen letztendlich
auch nichts mehr man sieht ja immer
wieder in amerika geht es immer wieder
solche amokläufe da kommen auch menschen
mit waffen in gebäude rein obwohl die
kontrollen dort sehr viel strenger sind
es ist ein einzelfall ist es ein
tragischer einzelfall aber ich fürchte
das sagt auch die polizei wir können
nicht überall sein und wir können nicht
jede tat verhindern wir können nur dann
versuchen so schnell wie möglich zu
handeln um die taten so so gut wie es
geht
wie soll man es ausdrücken dass das sie
klein bleiben dass es nicht so großen
auswüchsen kommt das ist das was die
polizei machen kann verhindern kann die
polizei solche amokläufe leider nicht
antonia nie war das für uns vor ort
vielen dank für diese einschätzung dem
ist im moment wenig hinzuzufügen außer
vielleicht noch mal kurz die
zusammenfassung das ist eben diesen
amoklauf offenbar einen amoklauf in
heidelberg gegeben hat der täter hat
sich selbst getötet vier opfer hat es
gegeben davon 1 aber das ist noch nicht
bestätigt letztlich das schreiben die
agenturen 1 jetzt auch an den schweren
verletzungen gestorben
das ist das was wir im moment wissen
dankeschön für die aufmerksamkeit das
wird natürlich noch heute weiter
gegenstand unserer berichterstattung
auch im fernsehen sein
wir sagen für den moment danke für die
aufmerksamkeit auf wiedersehen und bis
später es gibt auch andere themen mit
denen wir uns dann heute wahrscheinlich
dann in bälde zurückmelden werden es
gibt dann unter anderem auch noch mal um
die korona maßnahmen der bundesregierung
ja aber das ist jetzt erst mal an dieser
stelle einfach eine zäsur und bis später
wenn ihr mögt danke auf wiedersehen
[Musik]